Earlier in the show, I gave you the details
of this cash crunch that's hitting the Donald
Trump campaign, where they've already spent
more than 70 percent of all the money they've
raised dating dating back to early 2019 and
are having a pretty serious financial problems.
We also already looked at Donald Trump yesterday
during one of these deranged press briefings
making very little sense, seeming furious
about journalists wearing masks and just insulting
people calling Joe Biden stupid.
Trump also absolutely lost it on Twitter yesterday,
tweeting and retweeting 70 times in one day.
Now, as I've said before, most normal people
with regular 40 hour a week jobs are too busy
to tweet 70 times a day.
I make it a point to try to connect with people
on Twitter and to at least do a little bit
of tweeting.
And, you know, I'm not that busy.
I'm certainly not the president of the United
States and I'm rarely tweeting more than three
or four times a day.
And Donald Trump with 70, 70 tweets and read
tweets yesterday.
Take a look at some of the outrageous things
that he tweeted, because the themes are important
here.
And there's actually a great Web site, Trump
Twitter archive dot com.
It lets you look at tweets much more at a
glance and look at tweet trends and themes
that we see now.
Earlier in the morning, Donald Trump retweeted
a whole bunch of stuff about black violence
and police being good, retweeting a bunch
of things from the always action account.
For example, Black Man exposes Black Lives
Matter police officers saves baby's life.
The reason why President Donald Trump was
elected.
And the reason why he will be elected again
with a link to an outrageous propaganda video.
So there were a bunch of those types of tweets
earlier on in the day.
Then Trump started insulting people, for example,
quote, Biden underperforming.
What else is new?
The story of his life attacking John Bolton,
his former national security adviser, saying,
just heard that wacko John Bolton was talking
of the fact that I discussed love letters
from Kim Jong un as though I viewed them as
just that obviously was just being sarcastic.
Bolton was such a jerk.
And then around midday.
Remember, this is just it's all day.
Around midday, Trump re tweeting about 10
tweets from an account called TV News HQ,
all propaganda videos, Fox News videos being
retweeted, tweets about the Dow, which, by
the way, has not been doing so well.
Stock market has not been doing well.
Recently, conspiracy theories and all sorts
of agit trash, as I like to call it.
And then, of course, Donald Trump getting
into the phase of the day where he just lies
about Corona virus, tweeting, quote, starting
to get very high marks in our handling of
the Corona virus, China virus, especially
when compared to other countries and areas
of the world.
Now, the vaccines plus are coming and fast.
And we're going to talk on the Friday show
much more in depth about what kind of impact
could we see from the vaccine announcement
that we're expecting in October from Trump,
not the vaccine distribution, but the vaccine
announcement.
And, of course, Donald Trump insisting that
he's just done so well on Corona virus.
I guess there's probably some people who do
believe it.
There are Trump sycophants who will believe
anything.
But, you know, more than one hundred and ninety
three thousand deaths.
When Trump said we would have 60000 deaths,
maybe by the time it was all said and done,
Trump said 15 cases would soon be zero.
Now, with 193, almost one hundred and ninety
four thousand deaths as of this moment, Donald
Trump insisting that he's just done really,
really great on Corona virus.
And again, going all day.
The tweets started at 7:00 a.m.
Eastern yesterday.
They ended around 9:00 p.m. all day.
Unless you were with the exception of when
Trump was doing the press briefing yesterday
afternoon.
He's tweeting every hour.
It is just tweets, after tweets, after tweets.
This is not normal.
This is not needed.
This is not helping.
This is worsening our relationships with our
historical allies.
This is very much something other than actually
dealing with the pressing issues that we're
facing today.
It does nothing for you, the American people.
And I know some people write off the tweets
as not important.
Donald Trump has chosen to communicate his
perspective and his positions to the world,
essentially through Twitter.
And if he is chosen choosing to use this tool,
then certainly we should be using it to see
where Trump's head is.
And it is not in a good place at all.
And it is being reflected in the polls.
And that's what I want to talk
about next.